.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS,
EXACTLY, BUT IT'S PRETTY
OBVIOUS.
GLENN GREENWALD IS AN
INDEPENDENT JOURNALIST WHO HAS
WORKED WITH SUB STACK AND JOINS
US TONIGHT.
I SHOULD SAY TO OUR AUDIENCE, WE
HAVE NOT TALKED ABOUT THIS, I
HAVE NO IDEA WHAT YOUR VIEWS ARE
ABOUT THIS.
I WAS TALKING TO OUR PRODUCERS
TWO HOURS AGO, JUST GET
GLENN GREENWALD, HE IS SMART,
MAYBE HE WILL KNOW WHAT THE HELL
IS GOING ON.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS GOING ON?
>> FIRST OF ALL, JOE BIDEN'S
CAPABILITIES, DEMOCRATS WERE ON
MSNBC COME IN THE PRESS,
CONSTANTLY WARNING BIDEN'S
COGNITIVE DECLINE WAS OBVIOUS
BECAUSE THEY WERE HE WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO STAND THE RIGORS OF
THE ELECTION AND WAS LUCKY THE
PANDEMIC HAPPENED THAT HE WAS
ABLE TO HIDE IN HIS BASEMENT, SO
THAT HAS BEEN A NARRATIVE THAT
CAME FROM THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
AND OBVIOUSLY IT HAS WORSENED
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS, BUT I
ACTUALLY THINK THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT'S GOING ON HERE IS
OBVIOUSLY, THE CORPORATE WING OF
THE MEDIA, THE LIBERAL CORPORATE
WING, IS LIBERAL, THEY ARE
ATTACHED TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, BUT WITH ONE
EXCEPTION, WHICH IS THEY REALLY
DO BELIEVE CONSTANTLY IN
MILITARISM AND WAR, THEIR
CLOSEST RELATIONSHIPS IN THE
MEDIA ARE WITH THE CIA, ARE WITH
THE PENTAGON, ARE WITHIN THE
NATIONAL SECURITY STATE.
THEY CONSTANTLY CHEER FOR WAR,
THEY CONSTANTLY WANT MORE WAR,
AND I THINK THAT THEY DON'T CARE
ABOUT THINGS LIKE CRISES AT THE
BORDER OR INFLATION OR
JOBLESSNESS, NONE OF WHICH
AFFECTS THEM.
I DO THINK, THOUGH, THAT THEY
ARE DEEPLY OFFENDED WHEN THEY
SEE AMERICA GREATNESS AS THEY
PERCEIVE IT FALLING AND FAILING,
AND THESE KINDS OF IMAGES ARE
ONES AMERICANS ARE NOT
ACCUSTOMED TO SEEING, LOSING TO
WHAT IS ESSENTIALLY A PRIMITIVE
FIGHTING FORCE IN THE MOST
HUMILIATING MANNER POSSIBLE.
SO I THINK THAT IT OFFENDS THEIR
IDEOLOGY WHICH BELIEVES IN
MILITARISM, WHICH CONSTANTLY
CHEERS FOR WAR, AND I THINK THEY
ARE BEING TOLD BY A LOT OF THEIR
SOURCES IN THE MILITARY AND THE
CIA WHO THEY REVERE THE MOST AND
WHO DID NOT WANT WITHDRAWAL --
REMEMBER, TUCKER, WHEN TRUMP
TRIED TO WITHDRAW FROM
AFGHANISTAN, THE CIA INVENTED A
LIE THAT RUSSIANS HAD PLACED
BOUNTIES ON THE HEADS OF
AMERICAN SOLDIERS AND LEAKED IT
TO "THE NEW YORK TIMES" TO
PREVENT TRUMP FROM LEAVING.
A LOT OF OFFICIAL WASHINGTON
DOES NOT WANT THIS WITHDRAWAL,
AND THEY DIDN'T WANT IT WITH
TRUMP, THEY DIDN'T WANT IT WITH
BIDEN, AND I THINK A LOT OF THE
ANGER IS COMING FROM THAT.
>> Tucker: SO, I WAS FERVENTLY
IN FAVOR OF WITHDRAWING AND I'M
GRATEFUL WE DID WITHDRAWAL, I'M
JUST OFFENDED BY THE HUMILIATION
THAT ACCOMPANIED IT.
WHAT YOU ARE SAYING IS THAT WE
IMAGINED CNN WAS CONTROLLED BY
THE DNC.
IN FACT, IT IS CONTROLLED BY THE
CIA?
>> EXACTLY.
THERE IS CERTAINLY -- LITURGICAL
ARE KIND OF THE SAME, USUALLY,
RIGHT?
OVER THE PAST FIVE YEARS THERE
HAS BEEN A MERGER BETWEEN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY NCAA,
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS REVERE THE
CIA, REVERE THE FBI, IT IS
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE --
I ALSO THINK, AND THIS IS KEY,
THAT THE BIDEN PLAN TO WITHDRAW
FROM AFGHANISTAN WAS FOUNDED AND
BASED ON A LIVE FROM THE
BEGINNING, WHICH IS HE KEPT
SAYING THAT THE AFGHAN NATIONAL
SECURITY FORCES WERE STRONG
ENOUGH TO WITHSTAND THE TALIBAN
ATTACK AND WOULD HOLD THEM OFF
AND THAT IT WOULD BE ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THE TALIBAN TO
TAKE OVER THE WHOLE COUNTRY.
HAD HE BEEN TRUTHFUL WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT ONCE WE
WITHDREW, THE TALIBAN WOULD TAKE
OVER, I THINK THE REACTION
WOULD'VE BEEN A LOT DIFFERENT.
I THINK THEY FEEL BETRAYED, AS
WELL, BY WHAT THEY TOLD HIM.
>> Tucker: I COMPLETELY AGREE
WITH THAT.
HE SAID THE OTHER DAY IN AN
INTERVIEW WITH ABC, HE SAID IT'S
UGLY WHEN YOU LEAVE, AND I THINK
MOST -- INCLUDING ME -- I WOULD
BUY THAT, COMPLETELY.
IT WAS A LION THAT WAS SO
INFURIATING.
IT'S INTERESTING, THOUGH, I'VE
NEVER -- AND YOU HAVE COVERED
POLITICS AT LEAST AS LONG AS I
HAVE, I'VE NEVER SEEN, LIKE, A
CABINET SECRETARY OR A SPOKESMAN
CONTRADICT THE PRESIDENT ON
SOMETHING MEANINGFUL LIKE THIS
REPEATEDLY.
WHAT IS THAT?
>> YOU KNOW, I MEAN, LOOK, A LOT
OF THIS IS SPECULATIVE, RIGHT?
WE DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO BIDEN'S
MEDICAL RECORDS --
>> Tucker: FOR SURE.
>> WE ARE NOT MEDICAL OR
PSYCHOLOGICAL PROFESSIONALS.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT JOE BIDEN, I
DON'T BELIEVE ANYONE WHO SAYS
THAT THEY DON'T SEE CLEAR SIGNS
OF COGNITIVE DECLINE.
I SEE THE DISCOMFORT IN THE
FACES OF KAMALA HARRIS AND
SECRETARY BLINKEN WHEN THEY ARE
STANDING BEHIND HIM.
EVERYTHING THAT HE SAYS SEEMS
VERY FRAGILE.
IT IS ALMOST LIKE YOU CAN SEE
THE LEVERS OF HIS BRAIN KIND OF
SLOWING DOWN AND NOT REALLY
WORKING WELL, AND SO HALF THE
TIME THAT HE SAYS STUFF, IT IS
LEFT TO THE REST OF THE
ADMINISTRATION TO GO AND CLEAN
IT UP.
I FIND IT UNCOMFORTABLE TO WATCH
THE PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES
SPEAK, AND OF COURSE COME HIS
OWN AIDES FEEL THE SAME WAY.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
I DISAGREE WITH HIM, OF COURSE,
BUT I FEEL SORRY FOR HIM EVERY
TIME I SEE HIM.
I'M JUST BEING HONEST, I FEEL
SORRY FOR HIM EVERY SINGLE TIME
BECAUSE IT IS AWFUL TO WATCH.
GLENN GREENWALD, I APPRECIATE
YOU -- THAT'S HOW IT FEELS TO
ME, AND HIS FAMILY KNEW, THAT'S
TRUE.
THAT IS NOT SPECULATION.
THAT IS TRUE.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THIS WAS